no because I don't think these sins are
always much more complicated than how
they're positioned facebook has done a
brilliant job of opening up to third
party applications the the issue isn't
opening up its platform it's it has more
to do with the individuals user graph or
social graph if you like which is who
their friends are and when you start
doing that you run into these privacy
issues it's it's fine for me to decide
you can find out all about me but is it
fine for me to let you see who all my
friends are maybe my friends don't want
to be known as my friends and so I
shouldn't necessarily have the right to
reveal or who all my friends are one
well used hypothetical example as
suppose I'm gay and suppose I'm
sensitive about that yeah you know in
theory you shouldn't even be sensitive
about it because it's okay but some
people are or they have to be in their
work or whatever and so if I have
friends on my favorite lesbian site they
might not want me to open up my social
graph to all my friends on Facebook who
could then say oh well that's
interesting Esther has all these gay
friends so people get outed by their
association with me I'm either it's a
very complicated thing and I may have my
own reasons for not wanting certain
people to know certain things like I may
have an ex-boyfriend that I don't want
to see certain things about my new
boyfriend because rather than heating of
I'm wanting to make him jealous i still
like him or you know it's just or i may
not want my mother to see pictures of my
stepmother not because of privacy but
because of a certain delicacy again i
have my own reasons for wanting to
control this information it's not quote
privacy but it's not something where i
want even my friends to plaster my
information all over the place
so it's it's a complicated thing what
Facebook did sir brilliantly was they
said we're we are not so much a single
community they're way too large to be a
community we are a platform on which
people can build communities but no we
don't want to be a public utility we
want to be a proprietary ultimately
money-making utility and negotiating
those shoals is really tough and
Facebook hasn't done without a bunch of
errors on the way but they're they're
basic this is what Yahoo should have
done and failed to do facebook is doing
it if their pioneering and they're
they're learning by trial and error and
every little errors being viciously one
it's it's a million small mistakes I
don't know I mean that they're the boats
we're all going by Facebook jumped on in
one of them and then turned it into a
much bigger boat
you